thank you yasir yes i'm here with uh
victor bologan
a uh chess player one of the strongest
chess players that moldova ever produced
now the executive director of fide
victor
welcome to the show thank you thank you
how are you very good welcome to
bucharest tell us a little bit how does
it feel to see
these top players back in action well
first of all i am
very happy that chess is one of the
first sports which
managed to do it and to come back to the
real
the highest level possible i mean we had
the candidates now we have this
grandchild store
and they see the they're more or less
they didn't forget how to move the
pieces it's good
definitely didn't forget uh how to move
the pieces for the past year and a half
there's been a lot of hurdles in the
world of chess tell us a little
bit how did fida deal with those how did
you guys put together the candidates the
longest uh
chess tournament in history in the
history yeah actually i was suggesting
them to
apply to the guinness book because
that's
really the longest competition in the
history of chess
but we actually again we are lucky
sports we
managed to organize very important
competitions online
and one of them was this online chess
olympiad
with many many more than 100 countries
participating
and with different time zones all that
we our team
we have very good team they succeeded so
uh
it was not like completely empty life
there was a lot of online chess
and that maybe kept the chess players
brain
awake absolutely that that was uh
incredible efforts by
fide the top players are definitely
getting a lot of action
but what about let's say the 2500 2600
professional chess players what does
fida has
in store for those guys well we try to
organize some competitions and
still i mean okay first of all we uh
increase the number of
the participants for the world cup now
we have over 200
which is a another chance for those
players exactly 25 2600
uh to participate in this world
championship cycle properly it will
start now in sochi
and actually in the beginning of july
so uh that's one thing what we did of
course
uh it was not possible to to move
everything
we had online uh but still we managed to
introduce this hybrid type of
tournaments which gave some
possibilities for the
that level of players to compete
especially in the zonal tournaments
so and of course many of them they found
themselves in teaching
you know that now chess professionals
almost everybody is doing both
playing and teaching so and teaching
online again that was a huge boom
of teaching chess online so that was a
possibility for them
to support them financially and i
wouldn't say that all the merits belong
to fide but at least the chess players
are still okay now
and of course we are aware that there is
not only alicia's players and we want to
organize more tournament for that level
of players
absolutely let's say chess has been
quite fortunate in that regard
allowing us to continue our activity
online
uh you talked a little bit about the
world cup
there's uh somebody big that's going to
play in the world cup can you tell us a
little bit more about that
well i don't know there is m guy guy
magnus maybe uh of course um
that's a world champion and it's always
prestigious to have the world champion
in the tournament and we'll see how he
will perform but we had some pro
some big names had problems in this
knockout system i remember
not losing the first game to the unknown
player actually i knew the guy very well
uh from france but uh nobody else knew
this name but he managed to beat
another in the first game so the
surprises might come even to magnus i
mean
the chess now it's quite uh challenging
you can play
like a 2500 player but that might be not
your day
so we'll see but of course it's good to
have the world champion in the
tournament of course it's great
great news for feed it's huge news for
fida thank you very much victor for
joining our show and good luck with all
the organizing this year thank you thank
you so much thank you thank you victor
guys back to you thank you